Ich bin für Sie und werde das erste Gespräch mit Ihnen führen.
Erstmal benötige ich ein paar persönliche Daten von Ihnen und dann sprechen wir über Ihre aktuellen Beschwerden.
Falls Sie Fragen haben, sollten Sie bitte nicht mich unterbrechen. Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ja, ich heiße Walter Schmidt, Herr Doktor, aber ich fühle mich nicht gut. Ich fühle mich sehr schlecht.
Welche Beschwerden haben Sie?
Ja, ich fühle mich seit 3 Stunden sehr unruhig.
Ich bekomme kaum Luft und mein Herz schläft sehr schnell.
Es ist schlimm. Vermutlich habe ich einen Herzinfarkt. Ich weiß nicht.
Atemnot?
Ja, Atemnot habe ich. Ich habe auch einen Engel geführt.
Ich muss das erste Gespräch unterbrechen, um ein EKG schreiben und Ihre Vitalparameter erfassen, Herr Schmidt.
Ja, ich bedanke mich Herr Doktor, ich fühle mich nicht gut.
Jetzt können wir weitermachen. Seit wann haben Sie Herzrhythmusstörungen?
Seit 3 Stunden habe ich. Mein Herz schläft am Hals. Das ist sehr schnell, denke ich.
Ich sterbe jetzt, Herr Doktor. Ich habe sehr große Angst.
Machen Sie sich keine Sorgen, bitte. Sie sind hier gekommen. Sie haben eine sehr gute Entscheidung getroffen.
Wir sind für Sie da. Wir tun alles für Sie, Herr Schmidt. Machen Sie sich keine Sorgen, bitte.
Ja, meine Hände sind jetzt auch zittern.
Haben Sie Schmerzen?
Ja, im Brustkorb habe ich Schmerzen. Ich bekomme nicht gut Luft.
Haben Sie Ein- oder Ausatmungsprobleme?
Weiß ich nicht. Ich kann nicht gut atmen. Und ein bisschen schnell atme ich.
Hatten Sie das schon mal?
Ja, ehrlich gesagt hatte ich seit 3 Monaten viermal diese Gefühle gehabt.
Ich habe viermal eine Notaufnahme besucht. Aber keine Lösung habe ich gefunden. Herr Doktor, helft mir bitte.
Waren Sie deswegen beim Arzt?
Ja, ich war in der Notaufnahme. Viermal.
Wie wurde es behandelt?
Sie haben mir Sauerstoff gegeben und ein paar Medikamente gegeben und zu Hause geschickt. Weiß ich nicht, was passiert ist.
Brauchen Sie Sauerstoffmask?
Jetzt?
Ja.
Weiß ich nicht, Herr Doktor. Sie sind Arzt. Ich bin nicht.
Ich habe Ihre Vitalparameter erfasst. Alle sind ganz in Ordnung. Machen Sie sich deswegen keine Sorgen.
Oh, freut mich Herr Doktor.
Ich kann Ihnen ein Sauerstoffmask geben.
Ok.
Haben Sie dagegen irgendwelche Medikamente genommen, Herr Schmidt?
Nein, nein, nein. Ich war beim Arbeiten und fühlte mich sehr schlecht. Deswegen komme ich hier.
Wie stark sind die Brustschmerzen auf einer Skala von 1 bis 10, wobei 10 am stärksten ist?
Ich kann nicht das beschreiben, aber vielleicht 5, 6. Weiß ich nicht.
Könnten Sie bitte diese Schmerzen genauer beschreiben?
Ja, ich habe ein Druckgefühl und ich kann nicht stechen oder weiß ich nicht genau.
Wann waren die letzten Probleme? Sie haben schon gesagt, seit 3 Monaten haben Sie 4-mal ähnliche Beschwerden.
Vor 3 Wochen hatte ich die letzte.
Haben Sie strahlende Schmerzen irgendwo hinaus?
Nein, im Brust habe ich Schmerzen.
Haben Sie Husten?
Nein, nein, habe ich nicht Husten.
Haben Sie Herzstolpen bemerkt?
Mein Herz schläft schnell. Weiß ich nicht.
Schwitzen Sie häufig?
Nein, ich habe keine Schmerzen, aber ich fühle mich jetzt heiß und ein bisschen schwindelig.
Ist Ihnen schwarz vor Augen?
Nein.
Haben Sie Fieber oder fühlen Sie sich fiebrig?
Nicht Fieber, aber ich fühle mich jetzt heiß. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich Fieber habe.
Haben Sie es gemessen?
Nein, habe ich nicht gemessen.
Wie gesagt, brauche ich ein paar persönliche Daten von Ihnen. Sie heißen Walter Schmidt.
Ich buchstabiere mal eben S-C-H-M-I-D-T.
Ja, D-T.
Den Vornamen W-A-L-T-E-R.
Ja, Sie haben recht Herr Doktor.
Wie alt sind Sie Herr Schmidt?
Ich bin 32.
Ihr Gebustdatum bitte?
6.6.1992.
Wissen Sie, wie groß Sie sind?
Ja, ich bin 1,78 Meter.
Ihr Gewicht bitte?
Ungefähr 70. 69 oder 70.
Haben Sie einen Hausarzt oder eine Hausärztin?
Ja, natürlich habe ich.
Wie heißt er?
Er ist Herr Müller.
M-U-E-L-E-R.
U-E.
Ich kenne ihn. Er ist ein guter Arzt.
Was sind Sie vom Beruf Herr Schmidt?
Ich arbeite im Büro. Ich bin Büroarbeiter.
Herr Doktor, ich bin unter Stress. Büroarbeiter sind sehr schlecht für mich.
Ich kann nicht genug bewegen.
In einem Unternehmen oder für was ist das Büro?
In einem Unternehmen sind wir immer in einem Zimmer geschlossen.
Ich kann nicht gut bewegen. Das geht mir nicht. Aber ich muss arbeiten.
Ich brauche Geld. Wissen Sie schon?
Sie haben Stress bei der Familie?
Ja, ich bin niedrig und wohne mit meinem Hund. Manchmal habe ich Stress.
Aber Sie haben Stress bei der Arbeit?
Ich habe Stress bei der Arbeit. Ich habe kaum Freunde.
Haben Sie lange Reisen in letzter Zeit gemacht?
Nein, nein. Ich arbeite immer. Ich muss immer über Stunden arbeiten.
Deswegen kann ich kaum Zeit für das soziale Leben.
Ist Ihnen übel Herr Schmidt?
Nein, ich habe keine Übelkeit.
Mussten Sie sich übergeben?
Nein.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit Herr Schmidt?
Ich esse alles, aber seit 3 Stunden kann ich kaum essen.
Seit 3 Stunden?
Ja. Und nach dem Beschwerden, ich fühle mich immer sehr müde.
Sie haben Herzrasen, Brustschmerzen und Atemnot.
Welche Beschwerden sind am schlimmsten Herr Schmidt?
Wer ist am schlimmsten?
Warum sind Sie hier gekommen?
Ich denke, dass ich sterbe. Ich habe einen Herzinfarkt.
Aber in der Notaufnahme haben Sie alles gemacht und haben mir gesagt, dass ich ohne befunden bin.
Das glaube ich nicht. Ich habe Beschwerden, Herr Doktor.
Nach dem Anamnesgespräch werde ich eine körperliche Untersuchung durchschauen.
Machen Sie sich deswegen keine Sorgen, Herr Schmidt.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit Ab- oder Zugenommen?
Nein, nein, habe ich nicht.
Ist Ihr Schuttelgang und Wasserlassen?
Ja, Sie sind gut. Kein Problem. Ich habe kein Problem.
Gut zu hören.
Ja.
Können Sie gut schlafen, Herr Schmidt?
Manchmal habe ich...
Ich schlafe kaum manchmal. Ich kann nicht gut schlafen.
Warum können Sie nicht schlafen? Wegen der Stress oder...?
Ja, vielleicht. Ich wache auf.
Und eine Stunde, zwei Stunden kann ich nicht nochmal durchschlafen.
Einschlafen und...
Haben Sie Einschlafstörungen oder Durchschlafstörungen?
Normalerweise schlafe ich und wache auf.
In der Mitte.
Durchschlafstörung, Herr Schmidt.
Seit wann haben Sie das?
Seit drei oder vier Monaten.
Diese Beschwerden haben mein Leben eingeschränkt.
Das fühle ich mich sehr schwer.
Ich verstehe, Herr Schmidt.
Ich fühle mich schlaf. Total schlaf.
Wir tun alles für Sie. Machen Sie sich deswegen keine Sorgen, bitte.
Sie haben schon gesagt, im Notarzt oder Notfall Medikamente genommen.
Wissen Sie das? Welche Medikament war das?
Sie haben mir etwas gegeben.
Ich habe Sauerstoff eingenommen und eine Flüssigkeit, weiß ich nicht.
Nach der Untersuchung hatten Sie keine Medikamente mehr gegeben.
Hat es Ihnen geholfen?
Sauerstoff, weiß ich nicht.
Ja, aber die Flüssigkeit und Sauerstoff.
Ja, das hat mir geholfen.
Haben Sie irgendwelche chronischen Erkrankungen?
Ich hatte vor sechs Monaten pfeifferisches Dürüzenfieber.
Was haben Sie? Könnten Sie es wiederholen?
Ja, pfeifferisches Dürüzenfieber.
Das ist ein Virus.
Wissen Sie schon?
Ja, ich kenne dieses Virus.
Waren Sie im Ausland?
Nein, nein.
Ich hatte Halsschmerzen und Fieber vor sechs Monaten.
Vor sechs Monaten.
Haben Sie noch andere chronische Erkrankungen? Wie wurde es behandelt?
Ich hatte Paracetamol und Ibuprofen eingenommen.
Wie lange hat es gedauert?
Eine Woche.
Haben Sie noch andere chronische Erkrankungen?
Nein, aber ich hatte vor fünf Jahren Autounfall und einen Körperanbruch.
Wann war das? Könnten Sie es wiederholen?
Autounfall und ein Körperanbruch. Vor fünf Jahren.
Vor fünf Jahren.
Und wurde ich durch einen Körperanbruch operiert.
War die Operation komplikationlos?
Ja, alles geht gut. Alles hat gut gegangen.
Haben Sie noch andere Operationen?
Nein.
Haben Sie Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten?
Ja, ich habe Nussallergie.
Wie reagieren Sie darauf?
Mit Jücken.
Haben Sie noch andere Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten?
Weiß ich nicht.
Wie viel Kaffee haben Sie?
Ich habe seit zehn Jahren halb schachtel Zigaretten.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Auch Su.
Was haben Sie mit?
Besonders am Mahallen mit meinen Freunden und Freundinnen.
Wir trinken ein Schnaps Bier oder manchmal Whisky, manchmal Wein.
Einmal in einer Woche oder?
Manchmal einmal, manchmal einmal pro zwei Wochen.
Ein Glas Schnaps oder?
Ein Glas Schnaps oder ein Glas Wein oder zwei Flaschen Bier.
Richtig.
Nehmen Sie die folgenden Fragen nicht persönlich aus medizinischen Gründen.
Fragen wir immer. Haben Sie Erfahrung mit Drogen?
Was meinen Sie damit?
Marihuana, Haschisch?
Nein, nein Herr Doktor. Ich habe keinen Kontakt mit Drogen.
Sie leben mit Ihrem Hund?
Ja, ja.
Sie sind leidig. Haben Sie Kinder Herr Schmidt?
Nein, nein natürlich nicht.
Gibt es irgendwelche chronische Erkrankungen in Ihrer Familie?
Ja, mein Vater leidet unter Depression.
Hat er noch andere Erkrankungen?
Meine Mutter hat Bluthochdruck.
Mein Onkel hat Angststörungen.
Haben Sie Schwester?
Nein, ich bin Einzelkind.
Sind Sie zuständig geimpft Herr Schmidt?
Ja, ja. Ich bin zuständig geimpft.
Treiben Sie regelmäßig Sport?
Ja, ich habe kaum Zeit Herr Doktor. Überstunden immer. Deswegen habe ich keine Zeit Sport zu treiben.
Herr Schmidt, meinerseits habe ich alle wichtigen Fragen gestellt. Möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen?
Ja Herr Doktor, ich habe große Angst. Was muss ich machen? Was lernen Sie? Was denken Sie? Was habe ich?
Sie müssen hier bleiben. Ich werde jetzt eine körperliche Untersuchung durchschuhen. Danach werde ich Blut abnehmen Herr Schmidt.
Aber machen Sie sich deswegen keine Sorgen. Wir sind für Sie da und wir tun alles für Sie. Wir tun am besten.
Was muss ich überprüfen oder?
Es ist zu früh etwas genaues zu sagen. Mit dem Ergebnis können wir entscheiden.
Aber ich hatte keine Lösung gefunden. Ich möchte eine Lösung finden. Können Sie mir helfen?
Wir sind ein großes Krankenhaus. Wir tun alles für Sie. Wir haben viele verschiedene Abteilungen. Wir finden eine Lösung für Sie.
Machen Sie sich deswegen keine Sorgen bitte.
Freut mich Herr Doktor. Ich bedanke mich darauf.
Gerne.
Dafür.
Ich möchte Ihnen gerne einen neuen Patienten vorstellen, den ich eben in der Notaufnahme gesehen habe. Hätten Sie kurz Zeit?
Ja bitte.
Es handelt sich um Walter Schmidt. Er ist ein 32-jähriger Patient. Er wurde am 6.6.1992 geboren. Er ist 1,78 Meter groß und 70 Kilogramm schwer.
Er stellt sich bei uns vor Aufgrund seit drei Stunden. Er ist bestehender und zunehmender.
Herr Kollegen, wer stellt sich heute bei uns?
Wer?
Im Notfallaufnahme. Im Notfallabteilung.
Wie heißt unser Patient?
Walter Schmidt.
Ja. Herr Schmidt stellt sich heute bei uns.
Sie haben gesagt nur Herr stellt sich heute bei uns.
Ich sage Herr stellt sich heute bei uns.
Okay.
Herr Schmidt stellt sich bei uns vor Aufgrund seit drei Stunden bestehender, zunehmender, zuckender Brustzimmer.
Im ganzen Brust sowie Nervosität.
Die Schmerzintensität wurde mit 5 bis 6 von 10 bewertet.
Er gab an seit drei Monaten dreimal ähnliche Beschwerden gehabt zu haben.
Er sei deswegen im Krankenhaus gewesen.
Jedoch bisher keine feste Diagnose gestellt haben.
Darüber hinaus klagte er über die neue Tachycardie.
Ja, die neue Tachycardie.
Er hatte Stress bei der Arbeit.
Begleitsymptomen liegen Trämo und Vertigo vor.
Die vegetative Anamnese ist unaufällig bis auf Inapetens seit drei Stunden wegen der Stress und wegen dieser Beschwerden.
Insomni, Typ von Durchschlafstörungen seit drei bis vier Monaten wegen der Stress.
Er hatte vor sechs Monaten eine Viralinfektion.
Die wurde mit Paracetamol und Ibuprofen behandelt.
Bei ihm wurde vor fünf Jahren eine Operation wegen Oberanbruch durchgeführt.
Er hatte eine Allergien gegen Nuss, die sich mit Pyroglytus äußerte.
Er ist raucher. Er rauche seit zehn Jahren eine halbe Schachtel Zigaretten täglich.
Er trinke wöchentlich ein Glas Schnaps oder ein Glas Rotwein oder zwei Flaschen Bier.
Drogenkonsum wurde verneint. Er ist ledig. Er lebt mit dem Hund, mit seinem Hund.
In der Familienanamnese fand er arterielle Hypertonie bei der Mutter, Depression beim Vater, Angststörungen beim Onkel.
Er ist Einzelkind. Er ist vollständig geimpft. Die Reiseanamnese ist unauffällig.
Meine Verdachtdiagnose lautet auf Panikattacke.
Dafür schiebte ich vierte Mal in drei Monaten ähnliche Beschwerden.
Bisher habe ich keine feste Diagnose gestellt.
Die Symptome sind typisch für Panikattacke, zum Beispiel Dyspnoe, Tachycardie, Tremor und Brustschmerzen.
Die Differenzialdiagnostik betrifft Coronärherzkrankheit, Lungenembolie und Herzrhythmusstörungen.
Zur Diagnostik würde ich zunächst eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Im Rahmen der Untersuchung würde ich zunächst die Vitalparameter erfassen.
Danach würde ich den Patienten inspezieren, palpieren und auskultieren.
Bei der Inspektion beurteile ich den Allgemeinen Zustand des Patienten.
Bei der Auskultation achte ich darauf Herzgeräusch, Lungengeräusch.
Danach werde ich Blut abnehmen.
Ich überprüfe das Blutbild, die Entzündungswerte, die Gerindungswerte und Troponin E, CK, MB sowie die Dimmewerte.
Ich überprüfe die Troponin E und CK, MB, um einen akuten Herzinfarkt auszuschließen.
Ich überprüfe die Dimmewerte, um eine Pulmonaeembolie auszuschließen.
Zu weiteren Diagnostiken, zu weiteren Abklärungen würde ich operative Diagnostik durchführen.
Um einen Herzinfarkt auszuschließen, werde ich zunächst eine EKG schreiben.
Danach werde ich Röntgen-Thorax veranlassen, um eine mögliche Lungenpathologie auszuschließen.
Gegebenenfalls werde ich CT-Thorax veranlassen.
Um meine Verdachtstagnose zu bestätigen, würde ich den Patienten stationär aufnehmen.
Ich werde eine psychiatrische Konzilverordnung verabreicht, um die Therapie zu optimieren.
Als Therapie empfehle ich Psychotherapie, Serotonin, Voxetin.
Das war alles.
Und was empfehlen Sie den Patienten?
Ich würde eine psychotherapische und antidepressive Medikamente, wie Zertralin, Paroxetin, Wellafaxin, gegebenenfalls.
Herr Kollege, wie können Sie die Pulmonaeenbolie auszuschließen?
Ich würde Blut abnehmen, um die DMA-Werte zu bestimmen.
Und ich werde ein CT-Thorax mit Kontrastmittel veranlassen.
Gibt es jetzt einen Bluttest, um eine Pulmonaeenbolie auszuschließen?
Ja, das habe ich schon gesagt.
Schnell oder speziell?
Blutgasanalyse.
Wenn der Patient eine Lungengefäßarterie hat, wie können Sie diese Diagnose stellen?
CT-Tomographie mit Kontrastmittel.
Wir können nicht genau diese Diagnose stellen.
Wie können wir?
Ich kenne diesen Test nicht, Herr Oberarzt.
Können Sie mir helfen?
Hören Sie, wenn es so eine Perfusion-Synthographie ist?
Ja, ich habe es gehört. Vielen Dank.
Können Sie uns diesen Test aufklären?
Leider, ich kenne diesen Test nicht, deswegen kann ich ihn nicht aufklären.
Herr Kollege, wie können Sie Herzinfarkt auswählen?
Am Anfang würde ich ein EKG schreiben.
Was bereiten Sie beim EKG?
Es ist eine St-Häbung.
Und gibt es andere Diagnose?
Ja, danach würde ich Blut abnehmen.
Was ist die Diagnose?
Die Diagnose ist operativ.
Ja, Corona angioha.
Können Sie die Patienten mit Angiogrammen heilen?
Gibt es einen einfacher Test?
Eine Synthographie für das Herz.
Nein, sehr einfach und strahlhaft.
Um Herzinfarkte auszuschließen?
Ja, ja.
Ich kenne nur EKG als einfache Untersuchung.
Hören Sie eine Eschokardiographie?
Ja, ich kenne es, aber bei der Eschokardiographie können wir nicht Herzinfarkte auswählen.
Wie können Sie bei der Eschokardiographie einen Herzinfarkt auswählen?
Bisher habe ich nicht gehört, Herr Oberast.
Herzwandbewegungsstörung?
Das ist ein langfristiges Befund.
Nein, nein. Rechtsseitig.
Ich habe das erste Mal gehört.
Und auch eine niedrige Eschokardiographie?
Ich wusste, dass wir die Befunde nach dem Herzinfarkt darstellen können.
Vielen Dank für die neue Info.
Sie haben gesagt, dass eine Katheter-Untersuchung möglich ist.
Können Sie uns das PTCA aufklären?
P-T-T-T-A-B-T-A-B-T-A-B bedeutet, dass das Coroner angeht.
Ich weiß nicht.
Sie würden mir aufklären.
Das ist eine bildgebende Methode.
Wir können Herzkranzgefäße darstellen.
Es ist nicht nur eine diagnostische Untersuchung,
sondern auch eine therapeutische Maßnahme.
Wir können gleichzeitig Ständ und Ballon durchführen.
Das ist eine schmerzhafte Therapie.
Deswegen geben wir örtliche Betäubung.
Das ist eine Untersuchung unter der Röntgenstrahlung.
Nach der Untersuchung bleibt der Patient in einem Coronerstation.
Braucht man nach der Untersuchung Vorbereitung?
Man braucht keine Vorbereitung.
Aber nach der Untersuchung bleibt der Patient in einem Coronerstation.
Wie lange? Und warum?
Es gibt zwei Möglichkeiten.
Radialarter oder Femoralarter.
Wenn wir mit Femoralarter in der Femoralarterien durchführen,
bleibt der Patient wegen Blut 6 Stunden in der Coronerstation.
Was empfehlen Sie bei der Patientin nach der Katheterunterzuchtung?
Bei der Patientin ist es ohne Bewegung.
Und?
Was noch?
Viel Wasser trinken?
Ja, wir geben Kontrastmittel.
Und wir vermeiden auch eine renale Ausschädigung.
Für renale Ausschädungen empfehle ich viel Wasser trinken.
Vielen Dank Herr Kollege.
Guten Tag Frau Oberstin.
Ich habe heute einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen.
Ich möchte Ihnen berichten.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit dafür?
Ja gerne.
Ich berichte über den 32-jährigen Patienten Herrn Walter Schmidt.
Der 1,78 Meter groß ist und 69 Kilogramm wiegt.
Herrn Walter Schmidt kam zu uns heute aufgrund seines heutigen Beschleunigungs.
Brustschmerzen, Dyskno, Palpitations, Vertigo und Tremor sowie Angststörungen.
Außerdem fühlt er sich heiß während dieser Beschwerden.
In den letzten drei Monaten besuchte der Patient viermal wegen ähnlicher Beschwerden die Notaufnahme.
Jedoch wurden ohne pathologisches Befunde festgestellt.
Zusätzlich fügte er hinzu, dass er während dieser Angstattacken Todesangst sowie Gefühl eines Herzinfarktes verspüre.
Darüber hinaus leidet er unter Asthenie und Fatigue, nachdem er Angstattack hatte.
Der Patient leide an vor sechs Monaten Epstein-Barbrys-Infektion, die mit Paracetamol und Ibuprofen behandelt wurde.
Er hatte vor fünf Jahren einen Autounfall und Oberarmbruch und wurde wegen einem Armbruch operiert.
Er hat eine Nussallergie, die sich mit Pruritis äußert.
Er ist vollständig geimpft. Die Reiseanamnese ist unauffällig.
Er raucht eine Halbschachtel Zigaretten seit zehn Jahren und die Anamnese von Alkohol und Drogen ist unauffällig.
In der Familienanamnese gab er an, dass sein Vater an Depressionen leidet und seine Mutter an arterialen Hypertronen leidet und sein Onkel an Angststörungen leidet.
Er ist leidig und wohnt mit ihrem Hund.
Die anamnestischen Angaben deuten am ehesten auf Panikstörungen, Angststörungen hin.
Die Anamnese ist an Angina Pectoris, Akut-Coronar-Syndrom und Pummoner-Emboli betrachtet.
Um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen, werde ich den Patienten zur Körperlichung untersuchen.
Dann werde ich Blut abnehmen, das Herz-Enzyme, Troponin, CK, MB und bestimmen lassen.
Ich werde ein EKG schreiben und mögliche Akut-Coronar-Syndrom ausschließen.
Ich werde auch einen Röntgen-Torax veranlassen und mögliche Lungen-Patologen ausschließen.
Ich werde die Patienten stationär aufnehmen, um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen.
Ein psychisches Konzil wird sinnvoll, um die Therapie zu optimieren.
Sie wollen die Patienten stationär aufnehmen?
Der Patient hat viermal eine Notaufnahme besucht und hat keine Lösung gefunden.
Deswegen werde ich den Patienten stationär aufnehmen, um eine genaue Diagnose festzustellen.
Ich denke, diese Patienten haben viele Labuntersuchungen gefunden.
Welche neuen Tests werden Sie machen?
Welche Labottests oder weitere Tests haben diese Patienten?
Ich werde die Patienten stationär aufnehmen.
Der Patient hat berichtet, dass in der Notaufnahme keine pathologischen Tests gefunden wurden.
Welche Labottests haben diese Patienten?
Ich habe keine Informationen über welche Tests durchgeführt.
Der Patient hat berichtet, dass er Sauerstoff und Flüssigkeit einnehmen hat.
Welche Tests haben Sie durchgeführt?
Ich denke, diese Patienten haben vorher eine Enzyme-Labo-Untersuchung und eine Echokardiographie.
Oder eine Angiographie.
Ich muss die Geschichte genaue lernen.
Bei der Untersuchung werde ich diese Fragen feststellen.
Der Patient hat eine Operation wegen Arm-Fraktur.
Der Patient nimmt keine regeln-mäßig Medikamente ein.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Können Sie die Echokardiographie ...
Die Echokardiographie ist eine besondere Sonographie für das Herz.
Ich versuche mit dem Herz, ob eine Bewegung oder eine Wandstörung, eine Wandschwache oder Herzinsuffizienz gibt.
Wir überprüfen die Ejection-Fraktion mit der Sonographie.
Das ist eine Schmerz-Arm-Untersuchungs-Methode.
Sie hat keine Risiko-Arm-Untersuchungs-Methode.
Zuerst tragen wir ein Gel auf der Betroffenen Haut, auf der Brustkorb.
Und mit Schalkopf bewegen wir Schalkopf.
Und mit Schallwellen beurteilen wir die Herzbewegung und Erkrankungen.
Okay.
Aber gibt es keine Familiengeschichte für Herzkrankheit?
Der Patient berichtete, dass seine Mutter unter Arterialhypertonie leidet.
Manchmal kann eine Arterialhypertonie einen Herzinsuffizienzverursachung.
Deswegen wird eine Echokardiographie sinnvoll.
Ja. Okay.
Ich habe keine weitere Fragen.
Aber ...
Können Sie uns die Echokardiographie erklären?
Die Echokardiographie ist eine Untersuchung für das Herz.
Mit Hilfe der Echokardiographie messen wir Herzsturm oder Herz-Elektrikaktivität.
Und wir können mit Hilfe der Echokardiographie Herzrhythmusstörungen beurteilen.
Das ist eine schmerzlose und risikofreie Untersuchungsmethode.
Und eine günstige und einfache Untersuchungsmethode besonders für das Herz.
Wie läuft dieser Test?
Zuerst verbinden wir Metallklempfe zum Extremitäten- und Brustkorb.
Und wir messen Herz-Elektrikaktivität.
Und beurteilen wir Herzrhythmus und Herzbewegung manchmal.
Das können wir beurteilen.
Braucht man vor der Untersuchung Vorbereitung oder nach der Untersuchung?
Ja, man braucht keine Vorbereitung vor der Untersuchung.
Man muss liegen auf dem Liegtisch.
Und natürlich den Körper, den Oberkörper besonders.
Man muss frei machen.
Man muss die Brustkorb und Brusthaut frei machen.
Und natürlich die Extremität.
Man muss die Sprunggelenks oder Handgelenks frei machen.
Bevor diese Untersuchung.
Oder oder und?
Und zusammen.
Hat diese Untersuchung alternative Methoden?
Elektrokardiografie oder?
Ja, ja.
Es gibt drei besonders elektrokardiografische Methoden.
Eine ist Elektrokardiografie im Geist oder Belastungs-Elektrokardiografie oder Dauerhaft.
Die elektrokardiografische Methoden.
Alternative Methoden.
Nicht gleich, aber die Echokardiografie kann auch Herzerkrankungen beurteilen.
Oder die Angiografie.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Die Angiografie kann auch Herzkrankungen beurteilen.
Wie viele Komplikationen?
In der EKG oder?
In der EKG, ja.
Oder Allergien.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Keine Allergien oder Kunststoffallergien.
Vielleicht kann man das verursachen.
Oder mit Hochdosen Elektrizität oder Sturm.
Ich weiß nicht, aber das denke ich kann eine Komplikation auftreten.
Gibt es keine Komplikationen und keine Allergien?
Keine.
Keine?
Elektrik verwendet.
Wir verursachen nur die Elektrikaktivität.
Wir verursachen keine Elektrik.
Ich habe drei Patienten aufgenommen.
Ich würde ihnen die Patienten vorstellen.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Ja, gerne.
Es handelt sich um Herr Walter Schmidt.
Er ist 32 Jahre alt und 1,78 Meter groß und 70 Kilogramm schwer.
Der Patient stellt sich heute bei uns wegen seit drei Stunden bestehender Dispnö,
Tachikardie und Thorax Schmerzen mit ohne Ausstrahlung vor.
Den Patienten sind die Schmerzen flüssig aufgetreten.
Er erwähnt, dass die Schmerzen drückend und stehend sind.
Die Schmerzenintensität wurde mit 5 bis 6,5 auf eine Schmerzskala bewertet.
Der Patient hatte früher vier Mal Schmerzen.
Deswegen war der Patient bei vielen Mal Notaufnahme.
Er wurde mit Flüssigkeit und Sauerstoff behandelt.
Die Therapie hat aber keine Verbesserung gebracht.
Die Symptome gehen mit Fatigue, Astehlen, Nervosität und Tremor in die Hand einher.
Die Vegetative Anamnese ist unaufällig bis auf Schmerzen,
Bechwerde bedingt Inapetens, Insomni und Vertigo.
Anfängerkrankungen nannte er seit acht Monaten bestehende,
Entschuldigung, vor sechs Monaten hatte er eine Dürzenfibakrankheit.
Für eine Woche wurde die Erkrankung mit Paracetamol und Ibuprofen behandelt.
Vor fünf Jahren hatte er einen Autoumfall und seine Oberarm wurde gebracht.
Er wurde bei dem Patienten eine Operation durchgeführt.
Er hatte Nussallergie, die sich mit Pyrithus uitschneidete.
Er trinkte seit zehn Jahren halb Schachter Zigaretten.
Er trinkte gelegentlich Alkohol, einen Schnaps oder ein Glas Wein.
Besonders an Wochenende.
Der Druck und Konsum wurde verneint.
Im Besuch auf die Familie Anamnese teilte er mit dem Vater an der Depression.
Die Mutter hatte eine arterielle Hypertonie.
Der Onkel hatte Angststörungen.
Er ist Einzelkind, vollständig geimpft, treibt keinen Sport.
Er arbeitet als Büroarbeiter und hat viel Stress.
Er lebt mit seinem Hund und hat keine Kinder.
Ich gehe von einem Verdacht auf einen Panikattack aus.
Da der Patient dafür typische Symptome aufweist.
Der Patient ist viele Male deswegen beschwerden,
Notaufnahme oder andere Arzt gewesen.
Aber es gab keine bestimmte Diagnose.
Er hat viel Stress und hat eine Tachikardie.
Das spricht für einen Panikattack.
Als Differenzia-Diagnose kommen Hypertroide, chronische Herzkrankheit und pulmoner Embole in Betracht.
Um meine Verdacht-Diagnose zu bestätigen, würde ich den Patienten
die vitalen Parameter überwachen.
Dann würde ich den Patienten mit körperlicher Untersuchung
das Herz und die Lunge auskürzen und inspektieren.
Neben körperlicher Untersuchungen würde die Labarunterzuchtung
ein Symbol für die Diagnose auf der Unfallseite sein.
Dabei würde ich Blutbild TSA3 und TSA4 und T-Diagnose
und T-Diagnose und die Pneumatikationen bestimmen lassen.
Außerdem würde ich den Patienten eine EKG schreiben,
um mögliche Herzkrankheiten auszuschließen.
Nach der EKG würde eine Eschokardiografie sein,
um mögliche andere Herzpathologien auszuschließen.
Außerdem würde ich den Patienten eine Röntgen-Torax durchführen,
um mögliche Lungen-Pathologien beurteilen können.
Dann würde ich die Gegenden fassen, würde ich den Patienten
eine Ventilation-Perfusion-Sintiografie durchführen,
um mögliche Pulmoner-Embolien auszuschließen.
Dann würde ich den Patienten eine Stationäre aufnehmen,
um meine Therapie zu optimieren.
Dann würde ich den Patienten Antidepressiv-Medikamente
veranlassen, wie DIAZEPAM zum Beispiel.
Wenn Sie sich mit dieser Vorgehensweise einverstanden sind,
würde ich mit den geplanten Untersuchungen fortfahren.
Ich verstehe. Denken Sie, dass es eine Pulmoner-Embolie für diese Patienten gibt?
Es könnte sein, weil die Patienten eine Displone und eine Tachikarte haben.
Ich möchte sicher sein, denn es ist möglich, denke ich.
Aber um diese Diagnose zu sichern,
möchten Sie eine Ventilation-Perfusion-Sintiografie durchführen?
Das ist nicht notwendig.
Ich werde Sie als erstes mit einer Tachikarte ausführen
und vielleicht auch mit einer CT-Tachikarte durchführen.
Aber wenn Sie diese Diagnose nicht bestimmen lassen,
würde ich den Patienten mit einer Tachikarte durchführen.
Aber im Labor möchten Sie eine ...
Ja, ja, das Labor ist sehr wichtig. Sie haben recht, das zu machen.
Das ist sehr wichtig für eine Pulmoner-Embolie.
Und?
Und da ist eine Blutgasanalyse.
Ja, eine Blutgasanalyse.
Okay. Und möchten Sie diese Patienten stationär aufnehmen?
Ja.
Warum?
Ja. Der Patient ist sehr stressig.
Und Sie haben viel Angst, wenn der Patient ...
Aber welche Therapie haben Sie? Welche Therapie werden Sie beginnen?
Ja, ja, Sie haben recht, Frau Berarsin.
Der Patient hat gesagt, ich bin viele Mal auf andere Arzt- und andere Notaufnahme gegangen.
Und eine Wende.
Der Patient hat viel Stress. Vielleicht, wenn wir ein paar Tage den Patienten im Krankenhaus kontrollieren oder beobachten?
Ja, der Patient hat viele Laboruntersuchungen.
Und ich denke, diese Patienten sind eine Klasseur mit vielen Laboruntersuchungen oder weiteren Untersuchungen.
Und ...
Ja, Sie haben recht. Aber jetzt ist es möglich, es gibt andere Probleme.
Vielleicht mit dem Lungenhundherz.
Man muss sicher sein.
Man kann sicher sein.
Und ich denke, es wäre besser, wenn die Patienten in der Aufnahme beobachten.
Aber es ist möglich, nicht stationär.
Sondern auch ambulant.
Ja, ambulant beobachten.
Okay.
Und möchten Sie uns die Syntagraphe aufschreiben?
Ja, Frau Berarsin.
Ich würde Ihnen ...
Syntagraphe.
Ja, Syntagraphe.
Ich würde Ihnen ...
Welche Syntagraphe? Schindelüse Syntagraphe? Knochen Syntagraphe? Herzsyntagraphe? Welche?
Lunge.
Lunge, Ventilatoren, Perfektion, Syntagraphe.
Ja.
Es ist etwas, was ich aber tun kann.
Ventilatoren, Perfektion, Syntagraphe sind eine große Bedingung.
Wenn man sich mit einer Lunge, mit einer Lunge durch die Staule,
dann kann man sich nicht mehr problematisch beobachten.
mit einer anderen Lunge durch die Staule,
um diese Unterzucht zu machen,
werden wir den Patienten eine radioaktive Stoffe injizieren.
Ja.
Die Bild der Lunge wird in Echtzeit auf einem Monitor dargestellt.
Nach der Unterzucht sollte der Patient viel Wasser trinken.
Dann wird er auf den Körper ausgescheiden.
Ausgescheiden wird.
Ja, ich bin fertig.
Das war eine schwierige Sache.
Ich hätte es nicht gesagt.
Ich weiß nicht, was die Leute sagen.
Das war schon schwierig.
Ich habe es schon gesagt, aber ich weiß nicht.
Das ist schwierig zu bezeichnen.
Zuerst wird ein Lüftung gemacht.
Erst wird ein radioaktives Gas in die Patientin inhaliert.
Dann wird ein Bild ausgebildet.
Das ist die Ventilationssynthes.
Dann wird die Patientin in ein Radio in die Stoffe ingeleitet.
Dann wird wieder eine Bildung gemacht.
Das ist auch für die Perfektion.
Das ist ein schwieriges Thema.
Wir haben es schon gemacht, um eine Sprachanträgung zu machen.
Wir wollten es aber nicht, um eine Sprachanträgung zu machen.
Wir haben es versucht, um eine Sprachanträgung zu machen.
Muss man die Patientin wirklich auf den Beinen bewegen?
Ich habe es schon gesagt.
Diese Patientin war schon oft in meinem Training.
Sie fragte mich, ob ich die Befunde der Laboren gesehen habe.
Sie fragte, ob ich die Befunde der Laboren gesehen habe.
Ich dachte, dass ich sie nicht gesehen habe.
Ich habe sie wiederbeissen, aber ich habe sie nie be exprimiert.
Und sie hat die Hitze hier Richtung換en?
Ich habe sie die Hitze nach steht, weil ich sie nicht sehen monde.
Wenn ihr einen Schlauchstab haben wollt, könnt ihr ihn auch.
Und weil er mit einem Schlauchstab kommt, kann man ihn auch für ihn folgen.
Denn er spricht 10-mal, aber es kann auch etwas im 11. Schlauchstab geben.
Also wie gesagt, ich bin selbst ...
Das ist der Grund, warum er mit einem Schlauchstab kommt.
Aber das ist ein wichtiges Punkt.
Ist es so, dass man einen Dossier neben dem Schlauchstab hat?
Sind es solche Schlauchstaben? Ja, das muss man fragen.
Ja, wie gesagt, wenn wir an der Mutter fragen, ist das schick.
Wenn ein Schlauchstab etwas sagt, kann er auch deinen Schlauchstab stärken.
Ich habe diese Schlauchstaben gefragt, habe die Tatsachen der Tatsachen gefragt.
Sie konnten nichts für alle finden.
Oder sie sagten normal.
Wenn ihr für das Schlauchstab panikiert seid,
dann habt ihr den Schlauchstab bereits gerichtet.
Und ich sage auch, Herr, das Schtraunen-König, das heißt Schtraunen.
Oder ich habe das gehört.
Ich habe es gehört, ja.
Das ist falsch.
Ich denke, dass du mit dem nicht sagst.
Das muss man mit dem sagen, oder?
Nur mit dem Schtraunen.
Ah, mit dem nicht. Dann mit dem Schtraunen.
Aber wenn es Schtraunen gibt, dann mit dem Schtraunen.
Schtraunen.
Aber mit dem nicht, um Schtraunen zu nennen.
Okay, sehr schön. Danke.
Und ich habe euch etwas fragen.
Wir nennen hier Wegen, Zeit, Bechdehender und so weiter.
Aber ich habe den Chatchip gefragt.
Er sagt, dass es nicht Bechdehender ist, sondern Bechdehendend.
Denn dort sagt er, dass man sich an Zeit bewegen muss.
Wegen ist nicht an Wegen, Wegen ist genetisch, Zeit ist dativ.
Was sagt ihr, Ulema?
Nein, Herr.
Ihr nehmt nicht an Zeit, sondern an Wegen.
Aber es passiert so.
Wir nehmt jetzt an Schmerzen, Bechdehender.
Wenn Schmerzen verändert, dann auch Bechdehender.
Ich weiß, aber wir nehmt an Wegen.
Ja, wir nehmen an Wegen.
Der Chatchip sagt, dass Zeit nach Wegen kommt,
also nehmt ihr an Zeit.
Der Chatchip sagt das nicht richtig.
Ihr habt euch den Kopf verabschiedet.
Ihr nehmt an Wegen und Schmerzen.
Ich nehmt schon an Nepele.
Ich nehm auch unsere Lehrerin an.
Die Frau ist nicht verabschiedet.
Ich bin total verabschiedet.
Ich habe mich auf den Kopf gerissen.
Nein, das ist richtig.
Herr, du nennen es Drogenkonsum nicht,
sondern Drukkonsum.
Das ist richtig.
Ich bin verabschiedet.
Du nennst es so.
Drogenkonsum.